okay guess what
River Griffin is back and we live here
we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite pie
[Music]
good
Ness
[Music]
what's up y'all we trying to step up the
game on the production value look at
this got more stuff like this coming but
you know we got the woo-woo on today's
episode I'm talking NBA Tick Tock band
in Utah
woolly mammoth meatballs and a whole
host of other weird and crazy news
sorry I'm late not feeling well today so
I'll tell you about my week but anyways
thanks for being here
[Music]
yeah
okay see how I did that
I got more stuff like that coming
I'm working on the layouts and stuff now
I was like you know what let me step my
game up right so anyways
Riverwood Griffin coming your way
um how you doing guys sorry I'm late uh
but as you say like I always say it's
terrific with Griffin thanks for being
here go to ericgirlfriend.com for news
and notes uh I always appreciate a good
subscribe you know what I mean subscribe
you know that helps me out make sure you
turn on those notifications when you
subscribe because that helps on Twitch
daily probably be on Twitch after this
so come check me out there uh you know
be a follower
um and then uh you know patreon you know
patreon just a support you know I'm
trying to figure out where I want to do
this because I got this new platform
kick I'm gonna talk to you guys about
that uh but anyways and uh also make
sure you check out my schedule because I
got some tour dates coming up oh check
out this new window
uh uh oh look at that one yes if you if
you're listening also thanks for
listening to the podcast regularly on
Apple and all the places you can get
podcasts Amazon music or wherever else
you get your podcast from I appreciate
that but yeah check out my new little
window we're gonna do it for this when I
go to like and stuff so uh these are my
uh tour dates I got coming up right now
gonna be in the Blue Room comedy club in
Springfield Missouri April 13th through
the 15th come check me out there
Louisville comedy club can't wait to go
there April 20th to the 22nd and then
the new Joe Rogan Comedy Mothership I'll
be in Austin April 28th to the 30th Zay
and then I got some you know real future
dates like Nashville and stand up live
and I'll be updating this because I get
new dates and stuff coming in regularly
so make sure you guys uh check that out
okay coming in regularly so yeah we're
gonna go to that page again when it's
time to like you know look at news and
notes
yeah I've been doing this on my gaming
channel if you come check out Eric
Griffin gaming daily I've been on my
gaming channel I've been like playing
with the layouts and stuff so I said you
know what
let me play with the layoffs on this so
I'm actually every week I'm gonna like
work on stuff and if you actually have a
overlay layout that you think hey Griff
I think this would look good and you
know you even want to make it for me
make it for me uh so we'll see how that
goes if you can see my voice I'm not I'm
not 100 percent
you know Rachel was sick and then I was
shooting
Lopez Show Lopez versus Lopez shout out
to George Lopez I was on his podcast
some months back and I really think that
like I planted to seed for like coming
on his show and then they had this park
come up last minute and they needed
somebody and it was kind of a big part
for the episode because it's like the
episode is about this person and how he
interacts with George on the show and so
you know I got it like on I got it last
Thursday to hit me up like hey there's
this part they're offering and it worked
the next day you know what I mean so I
had to go in the next day and if y'all
don't know how network television
there's a lot of writing that goes on a
lot of rewriting I'm saying so even if
you memorize all the lines
by that night even while you're
rehearsing and then by that night
everything's different so it's like it's
like you have to constantly update so
it's like a whole thing so I did that I
was supposed to go to uh do shows with
Matt Rife in
I think it was Rhode Island so I had to
cancel that show with I had to tell them
yo dude I'm book I booked this thing so
I had to go do that so I didn't get to
go do that and then like so I'm and then
Rachel's like not feeling well coming
back from Fashion Week she wasn't
feeling well
you know so I was like babe you know I
think you know so we kind of like
staying away from each other and all
that but we still
it's still
I I'm I got sick
I feel like you know but I've been
fighting it you know
doing all the uh whatever you're
supposed to do when you're fighting
sickness so
[Music]
um
yeah so like I say Rachel are going to
Fashion Week oh I want to show you guys
speaking of that so this is a kind of a
cool thing
I was talking about it last week so you
know so Rachel was she walked in fashion
week and she actually was the poster
she was actually the poster for Fashion
Week like all the like the around the
city of El Paseo and Palm Springs Rachel
was the uh
she was on all these flagpoles and stuff
so I was like I got to get one of these
so I put out an Instagram post about it
like yo anybody in with the city because
I'm sure they've taken them down they
just got them they probably just thrown
them all away but I would man I hope we
could get one of these like to both of
them because I would frame both of them
and then we could put them like in our
hallway it just you know as two separate
art pieces but connect it you know that
kind of thing
so yeah but that's that's actually
really cool that that's a picture of her
this all it was all over the city man so
shout out to my lovely lady
Fashion Week yeah so I did the Lopez vs
Lopez uh you know and that's kind of
that's really cool that George Lopez is
doing the show with his daughter based
off their life so you know and it's like
if there are 20 episodes Al madrigal's
on it my other buddies we were in I'm
dying up here together so that was kind
of cool so that's what was going on
uh with me this week and still so last
night was the shoot day the the audience
day and so I'm in there and I'm feeling
okay and then as soon as I started to
get home I was like
I'm feeling it so today I was just like
beat up so I got shows tonight I got a
show and I don't even know if I'm gonna
go but you know like I say to show must
go on so then this morning I was
supposed to get up early I wanna I wanna
try to do this podcast at 10 A.M on
Wednesdays but I just I wasn't
I just oh man you guys don't even know
and then I had this lunch meeting so
here I am but we're here as always
all right let's go over comments
comments uh from Over the week yeah so
then you know there was a whole big talk
about the volume everyone commenting
about the volume on the chat is watching
it live the sound I believe when you
listen to the audio version It's lower
when you listen to it through Apple
podcast or Spotify or whatever that's
from Jamie Randolph I don't even know
what that means I hope the volume sounds
good now I have no idea I you know I'm
doing it live and I have my uh what do
you call it you know I'm doing it
through my uh
um
oh I had to do see this is like causing
a buzz the uh
all right let me turn that off yeah
so yeah so I hope that that
works out I hope it sounds good is what
I'm saying
um let's see come Cami I don't know if
this is Cami when you guys have these
weird usernames I don't know what to
even think of it but it says as a young
person I look up to Eric's thoughts and
wisdom so much and as a woman I do want
guys to talk to me also women who just
want to be friends meet people
spontaneously
okay so you know that's nice comment
about I had a whole big rant last week
about you know this whole stupid social
experiment they're doing with rings you
know so dumb
Steve Beck I watched swarm and the end
of the first episode really took me by
surprise and made me a little weirded
out the show is amazing and definitely
captivated that's from Steve Beck yeah
man you gotta watch uh swarm I talked
about it last week one of the weirdest
shows I've ever seen in my life such a
weird show
uh let's see
uh uh
somebody said I don't even know their
name well I'm not even gonna their name
doesn't even mean anything so I don't
know it's like a weird it's not even
like a it's just one letter that's weird
uh let's see Terry hunt you're very
quick on your feet you're awesome don't
stop doing this it's great oh well
that's fun thank you for saying that
um
let's see I don't know what this even
means
Kickin Wing I know the real Eric
wouldn't would wear elbow pads while
riding a bike
Maybe
I'm not trying to get my elbows toe up
you know what I mean
um okay so squid games that's a funny
name squid games gotta say how I dig
your gotta say how I dig your takes in
general don't always agree like with
Star Wars being a good with their latest
projects but I think you're pretty spot
on with a lot of takes and you make it
entertaining
stay woo-woo
so there you go thank you you know I
appreciate that and now it's from squid
games
um yeah I got a lot more great comments
if you want your comment read you know
and I love good engagement
a lot of the haters
a lot of the haters on the other like
when I'm doing golden hour all those
hater people in the comments like last
week I was in the comments on that
because we were making a joke about like
oh we gotta look at the comments to see
who agrees and doesn't agree so it was
funny and then like in the comments
there's always some there's always some
idiot who used to be over here who I had
to get rid of who's like oh he doesn't
like when you disagree with him it's
like that if you really watch me you
know that that's not true uh I just
don't like [__] you know what I mean
but you could uh disagree all that all
you want let's have a good back and
forth I love a good back and forth
that's what it's all about so thanks
everybody for being in chat and yes this
is live lost we are live and so I'm
looking at YouTube chat right now and we
are live
so there's this new website
called Kick
um and they you know and I made an
account I made a kick Eric Griffin
kick.com Eric Griffin gaming because I
was like oh let's see and then you know
they're trying to compete with twitch
and all the online gaming Services they
pretty like their UI pretty much copy
twitch so I don't know if that's gonna
fly and as of right now you know you
could get subscribers and they're given
a hundred percent of the subscriber
Revenue to the the Creator minus
the fee
and so at first I was like oh wow this
is gonna be pretty good but I don't know
if they're necessarily ready
not kick Kik k i c k.com
I don't know if they're ready to compete
with twitch because twitch has the prime
Subs
different tier subs and even though
twitch takes a lot of the profit they
take a bigger percentage of the the
subscriptions they also they'll offer
ads man like you get ad Revenue tip
Revenue there's like all types of ways
to generate Revenue so what I see for me
you don't need as many subscribers on
Twitch to make
the same amount of money you would have
to make for double the subscribers on
this new platform and eventually they're
gonna have to give money and so I don't
know apparently they're like
attached to gambling and
um cryptocurrency so now everybody's off
crypto now you know so anytime you hear
like cryptocurrency now you start to
feel oh is this some shady stuff going
on so I don't know I mean I I've
streamed on it a few times I do have an
account so we'll see if it you know if
they if it's you know legit you know I
don't know
I don't know so and if anybody has any
information about Kik out there I'd be
more than happy to uh you know
you know send an email to me or
something if you know something I don't
know if you're one of these nerds out
there you know what I mean
so anyways Joe Hill thank you for the
Super Chat man I appreciate that great
uh 10 super chat greatest defensive team
uh o4 Pistons they were pretty good
that was a great uh defensive team
um just statistically statistically they
probably were the greatest statistical
defensive team of all time I think they
held every team under 100 points all
year even in the playoffs so I don't
know
good segue into uh NBA talk guys NBA
play you know I haven't been talking
about the NBA a lot this year you know
haven't been talking about the NBA a lot
this year because I just you know I just
I'm not into it as much as I used to be
you know what I mean
not into it as much as I used to be uh
but you know let's look at the NBA
playoff picture right now this is the
updated bracket according to Bleacher
Report right now
so right now like in the East you got
Milwaukee looking like the best team in
the East uh Boston coming in second and
then Philly with the leading candidate
for League MVP right now I think it's
Joel and Mead the dude's balling I think
he probably got he probably feels like
he got robbed last year so here we are
and you got Cleveland after all the
trades they did and getting Donovan
Mitchell Cleveland looks like a legit
team New York the surprise team of the
east in my opinion like how the hell are
they in the real playoff picture
and Brooklyn's still in it man
traded away from
the Suns
Jack Vaughn got these guys playing you
would think you lose Kyrie Irving and
you lose Kevin Durant that that's it
they're just gonna plummet Ben Simmons
is a joke like that guy they need to
just that guy needs to just go away go
away Ben Simmons uh they shut him down
you know I don't know what he thinks he
thinks he's he thinks he's Kevin Durant
and Kyrie Irving so he's like why am I
still here dude you in the playoffs
you're in the playoff playoffs not even
the playing game you know wait hold up
sorry guys
I'm really not feeling well I shouldn't
be you know but you know I'm doing it
live so it's amazing when I was on
remember when Rogan used to do it live I
didn't even realize he was doing it live
and I like blew my nose
he was like yeah because I was like I
got a [__] nose dude I gotta do it
um
so Brooklyn and then in the playoff race
in the East you got those other teams
Miami with the winning record Atlanta
and then then it's all below 500 teams
Atlanta Toronto Chicago Indiana
Washington Orlando so before I even talk
about the NBA I just I do want to say I
do enjoy the play-in tournament I think
the play-in tournament is a great
addition to the NBA and I think it has
made it better A lot better because now
you're talking about
there's something to play for even up to
the end of the season so you're going
you want to succeed and you have to
fight for that six seed so if you look
in the East right now
you're talking between
um wait what's going on here
you're talking between New York Brooklyn
Miami Atlanta there's like three games
with like 10 games left so this could
switch and you could be in the playoffs
without having to do playing games so
you have something to play for at the
end of the season and I think that's
good for the fans so right now I think
the East is the better conference I
think Milwaukee Boston Philly one of
those three teams in my opinion is going
to win the championship I just think
they're just more complete they play
better defense than the West I think
that they have just as many stars I
think there's better coaching I think
that uh though the East is going to win
the championship this year and I'm
getting interested in it as as it gets
towards the end here I'm starting to
like really get into it
oh this is like the Bleacher Report seed
predictions right there so let's go to
the Western Conference now Denver's
still in number one don't believe in
them I just don't they've never done
anything I don't think they're gonna do
anything this year at all I think
they're just they're just like window
dressing they've had great regular
season but I don't think it's going to
carry over into the playoffs Memphis
surprisingly is the number two seed even
after all that nonsense with John Morant
with the gun in the club and getting
suspended for eight games they're
showing that they are a really good team
that they can lose their best player the
face of the franchise for eight games
and maintain the second seed in a wide
open conference man wide open
Sacramento surprise team Sacramento New
York to me are the surprise teams of the
Season all right New York just the way
they've been playing is is just wait
what's going on with my sound man I'm
crackling right now I don't know how to
stop that all right sorry about that
um
you know so I think Sacramento is like
the surprise team Mike Brown doing
finally you know coaching his ass off so
good for him Coach of the Year candidate
right there you know so the way they're
playing Sacramento is the number three
seed and they still have a chance to
move up be number two Phoenix okay so
now you got Phoenix and we'll get into
Phoenix after this and you got my
clippers
they had a devastating injury to Paul
George once again the Clippers are
cursed man they just are cursed okay
like there's there's no way the Clippers
shouldn't have at least one or two
championships all the way back from the
Chris Paul era tell the Kawhi Leonard
period now you know it's crazy man it's
crazy
Dallas uh no I'm sorry uh and then you
got Golden State defending Champions
they just got a Winner's mentality man
Golden State
they're winners you know they got Pride
you know uh Klay Thompson came back from
this injury and he was like I'm coming
back I'm coming back and he and he's
proven that he's not he hasn't lost it
you know so who knows man and then you
got to play in Minnesota New Orleans
Lakers Oklahoma City Dallas Utah
Portland those are the guys so Oklahoma
City Dallas all these teams going up to
the number five going up to
um Phoenix at four at 39 and 35 all
these teams from four to ten they can
flip-flop they can flip-flop so
I don't know
the big team right there that we're
looking at number nine right now is the
Lakers
look I ain't no sports analyst I'm just
giving you my thoughts and I'm telling
you something right now
I think LeBron James is more hurt than
he's letting on but he's 38 years old
and I think that that tendon injury he
has in his foot
he's just gonna play through the pain
and probably have to retire you know I
don't know like he had the funniest
freaking quote I just I it's so arrogant
and I loved it they asked him about his
foot injury and LeBron goes
he goes to ask him did did you need to
get surgery and he was like yeah two
doctors said I need to get surgery so I
went to some different doctors he said
and when the doctor said I'm healing
faster than most people
and and he and they said well who'd you
go to and he goes I went to the LeBron
James of feet doctors
he went to the LeBron James of foot
doctors he said he went to the LeBron
James defeat like
are you kidding me like that is so
arrogant I love that
I just feel like
um I feel like LeBron James
you know I don't think
it reminds me of the Grant Hill injury
and it ruined Grant Hill's career
because he played on that ankle injury
and he never was the same and Grant Hill
was like LeBron James Michael Jordan
type Grant Hill was going to be like the
greatest one of the greatest players
ever like Mount Rushmore type talent and
he was headed to that trajectory hurt
his ankle and then he never was the same
again so what I'm saying is LeBron's 38
he's at the end anyway he already got
the all-time scoring and he's like I
can't get surgery right now and go
through a recovery and by the time I can
play at a high level again I'm I'm 39
40. so I don't know if we're getting the
full story but he might be like you know
juicing up man who knows whatever they
put in like the painkiller and all that
kind of stuff you know I just don't know
if LeBron's ever going to be the same
again I just I've said this before I'll
say it again LeBron KD these people like
those two in particular they will never
play 82 games again ever
ever
you understand Kevin Durant will never
play 82 games again ever he will always
get hurt okay he can't you can't play
like that at that high level be 35 years
old and expect that your body's gonna
hold up with that frame he has with how
he plays how great he plays the practice
the amount of pressure he's putting on
his muscles and tendons and everything
he will never be the same
so it is what it is you know
and with LeBron same thing he's been
injured every single year of his Lakers
tenure the first year they missed the
playoffs because he got hurt and then he
had to rest in the bubble and then he
won the championship and now didn't make
the playoffs last year now barely trying
to squeak into the playoffs this year it
has not been a successful run in terms
of like you know the success you expect
of the Lakers and LeBron James going
after going to eight straight finals you
know it's like but what a spectacular
career we won't even get into that so it
would be nice if the Lakers make the
playoffs so we'll see what happens you
know what I mean we you know we will see
what happens man so it's just it's it's
interesting to look at this playoff race
right now in the west because I don't
trust none of these teams none of these
teams make me go and I don't think any
of these teams can beat the Eastern
teams in a seven game series none of
them I don't think any of these teams
can beat
any of these but Milwaukee Boston or
Philly I don't think any of these
Philly's the only one that I think you
know and that's because Doc Rivers be
choking the games away with this crazy
ass coaching so who knows guys
who knows uh what what's going on with
that so yeah so that's that story
um okay let's keep going with all these
uh crazy stories I saw so I don't know
if you guys remember that I was talking
about how they're like trying to get and
you know extinct uh species back these
scientists found a way so now this you
know Australian company resurrects flesh
of a lost species to demonstrate
potential of meat grown from cells
and it just made me think like damn is
this like is this what we're going
towards like are we gonna go away from
cows and now we're gonna uh be growing
meat in
yeah we're gonna be growing meat in a
laboratory is it are we gonna be okay
with that like well like what's your
initial thoughts about it guys
like what's your initial thoughts about
it I would love to hear people's
thoughts in uh the the comments
um
let's see uh meat from a lab I'm gonna
put a poll up meat from a lab
yes or no
you know are you okay with it you know
what I mean
so I don't know
I just don't know I mean I think it's
that kind of thing
you know it's like you know it's like
you we just we're just not used to it
you know what I mean we're not we're not
used to it like what is like what does
this mean you know what does this mean
like a science like where is science
going and are we okay with it
uh it's a weird it's a weird thing and I
just think it's one of those things that
it could be great it could be more
healthy for us it could be like you know
what it's just like it feels very clony
you know like is this cloning technology
like what is this right now like is this
you know what I mean like is this is
this okay or is everybody okay
is it safe is it like you know we're
gonna you know is it gonna bring
diseases I don't know it could be like
really
healthier safer alternative option
that's better for the planet to make
meat from these cells I mean I don't
know it's just that we're like
this reminds me of
the autonomous driving like cars that
drive themselves
we're so nervous about this technology
like there's a part of us that like we
go oh I don't trust this I don't trust
science I don't trust the computers but
ultimately this is probably going to end
up being the safest way to drive I would
love to see the statistics about
accidents I'm sure there are there must
be way down with the automatic braking
the lane assist with the the the the you
know the beeping when you're like I know
I've I know my car has stopped me from
being in like five accidents in the last
five years because you know maybe I'm
looking down and then my car goes and
then I'm like oh [__] and then my car
stops I've been on that's happened to me
a couple times on the freeway or
different places so like you know Lane
like you trying to go over and your car
beeps doesn't let you go into that lane
so I'm sure accidents are way down so we
go but it's something psychological
about it that we're just not ready for
it
I feel the same way about just like uh
science meet
whatever you call it like are we really
ready are we ready for meatballs you
know are you ready for some meatballs
you know hot yeah somebody's talking
about hot dogs hey hot dogs are already
like a mishmash of but at least we know
it can't like what it's like if you're
if you're a humanitarian or if you're
like a vegetarian a vegan if you're one
of these like animal rights activists I
think this is the way you'd want to go
uh uh you know this is like this is like
like
this is gonna be the new vegan
restaurants
okay that's what this is gonna be
this is gonna be the new vegan
restaurants where the vegan [__] is not
gonna be
um
what is all this cookies and all this
stuff dude [__] internet is like
crazy I don't know what's going on here
me you know so so then the new vegan
restaurant's gonna be like yeah you
could get a porterhouse steak in here
and it's
laboratory growth you know so that's
where you you can get that in there so
then vegan is going to become this new
thing where it's not going to be
plant-based and all this stuff it's
gonna be like organic healthy or who
knows I would love to uh I would love to
know if they're like a scientist out
there that can explain to me how to do
it you know what what is this process is
this leading us to
is this going to lead us to like you
know if you can make meatballs
uh steak why can't you make hearts and
kidneys I mean isn't that the direction
we're trying to go in with this sort of
Technology but people don't want to talk
about that I mean if somebody needed a
heart transplant is there a way now that
we can like get their own DNA create a
heart in a laboratory and then put that
heart in their body and it'd be more now
they can live longer because you know
and things like that
uh uh you know I don't know I just I
just isn't it a fascinating thing to
think about I mean it's just a
fascinating thing to think about but I
just think that
this sort of technology I remember my my
great aunt
my great honor was visiting Belize you
know when I was a kid
and
you know oh man it was so rural you know
wooden houses and like open gutters with
like sludge in it just nasty that water
from a vat but they just started getting
like refrigerators and televisions
so I remember like this feeling that you
got from my great aunts they were 70 80
years old and that you know she has a
refrigerator that she don't turn on
she was like oh I'm not wasting
electricity on it like she didn't even
understand the idea that the
refrigerator was helping her
I remember that she had this um
so she had a TV so now they're starting
to broadcast television it's the first
time she and she told me don't turn it
to channel 13 because the devil is on
channel 13. and what it was is that they
were just showing some movie like King
Kong or something like that you know and
it was like that's like you know how she
thought about it you know she just she
just thought about it as like oh this is
like you know magic this is evil uh you
know so it's like
it's it's it's crazy
um you know what I mean like it's it's a
it's a weird so I'm saying
that's we are my great aunt right now
when we started thinking about
Pro like this
meat grown from cells
you know like right now we're at the
stage where we feel like we're fear the
fear we have of it the the fear of the
unknown and and our brain goes to like
this can't be right it can't be right
it's got to be something you know bad
about it but who knows I mean the
possibilities uh are endless
so you know who knows where this
technology can go so I just thought that
was a weird ass story uh that was you
know weird story of the week because I
remember talking about how they were
trying to like bring back the dodo bird
and the Willy Mammoth and so it's the
same kind of thing the company you just
kind of go what are you talking about
so I don't know all right big thing in
the news guys big thing in the news was
Utah is trying to ban under 18s from
using social media without parental
consent
all right so what do we think about this
all right let's finish with this one
poll first end poll okay and that's and
so everybody said no one to meet by the
way
everybody was no on the meat
okay man tick tock
all right let's just ask the community
so you know there's all this talk about
Tick Tock and it's a Chinese company and
blah blah blah and they're stealing your
data and even Rogan was talking about it
one day about reading the terms of use
and seeing all the the the the things
that we're agreeing to that they can
just look in your phone all the things
that they could do okay so nobody's for
that okay
but this is a greater conversation about
the effects of social media on young
people
and there is something to be said about
because like I said last week in my rant
last week when I was talking about
you know
like how can uh you know like all of the
[Music]
um
how people don't communicate with each
other they're not talking to each other
they're not you know you don't forget
about pheromones and using your your
senses to communicate I mean so there is
something that's like you know you know
they have studies about this at this
point you know at this point like you
know what are we talking about like
they're showing that you know social
media there is an effect that social
media has on young people so like at
what point are we gonna like what at
what point are we gonna listen to
the uh
are we gonna listen to them and be like
all right well maybe they have something
maybe there's something to be said about
this like what like you know like what
are we gonna do about this
you know it I mean do you think there is
something
to this that it is affecting our kids
brains and are stunting their growth in
terms of like social interaction and
making them low self-esteem and making
them feel terrible you know I don't know
you know what I mean I mean I think I
think everything needs moderation yeah
like and I think you know we we everyone
could use some moderation in their life
you know I don't think if you should be
allowed to just
I mean that's just part of the seven
deadly sins right is uh
gluttony oh you know all that stuff so I
don't know I mean so they want to like
you know you need parental consent I
mean I think there is something to this
I mean I think there's something to this
I mean
and I'm not usually with a state like
Utah and some of their you know weird
stuff going on but this might not be a
terrible thing
it might not be a terrible thing at all
I mean you know
uh somebody's saying to chat this is a
parent's job yeah but it is a parent's
job but then you also send your kid to
school
so like so like you're not watching your
kids 24 hours a day
you know so you're hoping then
that
when your kid goes into the 7-Eleven he
can't buy a beer or she can't buy a beer
because there are laws in place that say
you can't buy a beer if you're under 21.
you're not there to be like oh let's say
parental consent
hey I'm okay with my kid drinking so no
you're not there all the time so there's
like there's like laws in place where we
go all right when I'm not there
the village is helping me raise my kid
that's the whole point of that
so
is this one of those things
you know is this going to be one of
those like is uh uh what do you call it
is Tick Tock one of those things that's
like no I think that
this is hurting people under 18 or
whatever the ages they're saying and we
need to have some moderation and we need
to make sure like that the parents
actually are getting involved that's why
you need parental consent I mean people
you know screaming about parental
consent it's like well think about that
then now we're making sure that you are
involved
because a lot of times you might not be
involved and you see like
Twitter man
Twitter is like just
there's just porn on Twitter
like I mean who who has their kid on
Twitter I mean is there any kind of like
parental consent with that because you
could just
search you know anything and all of a
sudden like you're seeing a full-on
pornography on Twitter
so
who knows you know who knows where it's
gonna go I mean I mean I just think
about myself as a kid I you know
porno for me I had to go to the freaking
the weird channel on my station and then
there was like a squiggly lines and
stuff going on but there was
but sometimes you can catch it you can
see a titty in the background you'll be
like oh [__] there's a Teddy you know it
was just weird back in the day and now
you know then then it's like a
restriction on pornography and you know
cable television took over and and then
the internet came and then the internet
is like Hey we're doing whatever the
hell we want
I was talking to somebody when I was
doing the George Lopez show one of the
makeup ladies really really great staff
over there and the crew shout out to
them but she was like one of the ladies
like said she left her phone at home
you know she's like I left my phone at
home
you know when you leave your phone man
you feel badass naked you leave your
phone at home it's like you don't even
have underwear on you know that feeling
you're like watch my phone and then
you're like oh my God
but then as a as someone older I think
about like there was a time when I
didn't have a phone man I mean think
about this
you leave your house
and the people that are there you're
gone from them there is no interaction
or being able to contact them until you
see them again
y'all would lose your mind
like young people in their relationships
right now I don't even know how you
would survive
how would you even survive not being
able to text your boyfriend [__]
all damn day
I mean
sends me stuff all day like
thought about it there is something good
about
you get into a fight
you're fighting you're like okay I'm
going to work
there is something good about being able
to like go to work
not text mean hateful stuff not you know
kind of Let It Go
by the end of the day
you're good
by the end of the day you're able to
walk in and be like hey what up sorry
about earlier
and now I missed you all day today now
you having a talk so there is something
I think that it should be like
maybe it's not even just Banning Tick
Tock or things like that but much maybe
just some should be some sort of like
minutes restriction on okay you can only
be on your phone but again but that goes
into the parenting too man
it's like you know can you watch TV can
you that was my thing and back in the
day it was just about do your homework
before you turn on that TV right those
days are done
right
who's who's whose parents are even
saying that if you're a parent out there
or even telling that to your kid your
kid's probably not even on the TV they
probably don't even turn the TV on they
don't even care about the TV
so like what do we do now like what do
we do what do we do what is this
generation
gonna be like yeah now it's video games
it's tick tock Instagram Snapchat all
the little mini micro shows and things
that are going on
you know I don't even know
so
yeah it's uh oh somebody said I had
magazines yeah I didn't really have
magazines
you know I would you know it's like you
had to like you had to get those from
someone
porno magazines were like tennis balls
you never bought them you just had them
you know like I don't ever remember
buying a tennis ball
but I always had a tennis ball to play
baseball with or you know you just had
tennis balls I don't know where they
came from they kind of were passed
around I guess but I don't ever remember
going to the store and purchasing a
tennis ball that's how I feel about
pornography there was never like I never
went to the store and bought a Playboy
magazine or whatever it was you just had
it you just it was like a hand-me-down
or you stole it from somebody's dad or
something I don't know
who knows who knows but anyways getting
back to it you know let me know what you
think in the comments is this uh
is this like is is this ban of tick tock
are we going in a good direction by
looking out for the kids or is this just
some like you know overreach by the
government again or who knows so I would
love to hear your thoughts about it in
the comments to me you know I don't have
kids yet so it's hard for me to even
make a but it sound to me it sounds okay
to me it sounds like the government's
saying hey you can't just like so now
you just can't download any app
the parent has to be like so that but
how are they going to do that is that
gonna be like with the you're gonna have
to work with the phone company to be
like okay this is a kid's phone he is
not allowed to download anything like
there's a message go to the parental
phone and the parents are like yo
what's up with this
you know what I mean can you do this so
we'll see
somebody Joe Hill thanks for the Super
Chat he said uh born in the late 80s
late 18 89 89s we always found our
tennis balls in the woods yeah
right
found tennis balls I don't know who it's
almost like somebody was buying tennis
balls going outside and just throwing
them in Parks you know like the tennis
ball people would be like yeah just get
some tennis balls and they had one of
those ball guns that you have at this at
the at the game and they would just
shoot them bow bow they put them in the
woods like Easter
they were just hiding tennis balls all
over the city because I don't ever
remember
I I don't ever remember buying a tennis
ball but I had a tennis ball always
all right
there we go with that and we did it I'm
Trucking along guys you know I'm not
feeling well today but I'm doing the
best I can
um all right so then here's another week
it's just weird [__] man there's another
some more weird [__] news news and notes
and things
is slap finding the next big thing or
just an unsporting stupidity like
is this really gonna be
like look at that guy's face dude look
at this guy's face
like are you kidding me
but I guess how is this any different
than
how's this any different than boxing or
MMA or anything like that
how is it
you know like is this going to be the
next big sport it seems like
I think that this sport can only be good
if it's regular people in it
you know like every week it's like hey
welcome to slap fine and we have uh
Sheila and Carmen uh Carmen says that
Sheila didn't take her order correctly
at the IHOP and didn't you know and
Sheila's anyway she didn't give me a
right tip and now we're gonna slap it
out I mean if it was like that then yeah
you know like if it was like oh yeah
somebody was in line at the DMV you know
and this this happened at the DMV and
the person behind the counter you know
it feels like you get to just slap it
you know anybody then I'm like okay
this is a professional like get your
[__] out I like it but like the fact
that there's like trained athletes
working on a slapping each other
I mean look at this dude's face man I
mean oh my God that's crazy
it's crazy uh I don't know if have you
ever been slapped I don't I can't
remember if I've ever been slapped
oh I don't I don't ever remember who
knows I probably have you know what I
mean I've never been just like I think
oh you know what
I remember one time I was slapped this
is so funny too
I was at
I was at the comedy club bar area okay
and I walked up on a conversation
between this girl and a guy
and the girl was saying to the guy
she goes
you know what the difference is between
and there was some City like like she
lived in Oklahoma City or some small
City she was coming to a coming to La
she moved to L.A she was like the
difference between living in whatever
and then moving to La I walked in on the
conversation at that moment and when she
said that she was like well you know the
difference between
um like Oklahoma City and LA and I said
right in the middle of the conversation
with them I go going from a nine to a
six
[Laughter]
it was just one of those perfect comedic
[__] moments you know just like I was
young my mouth was running and it just I
just did it with it was just uh it was
just a perfect time perfect moment going
from a nine to a six and she just turned
around and slapped me
and I remember being like you know what
I deserved that one I got thank you you
know what I'm taking that one for the
comedic team you know what I mean it's
like so
what have you been slapped for
what have you been slapped for out there
I would love to know that in the
comments who's been slapped and why
somebody said they got slapped for
cheating
yeah I can see that
you know I mean you know it is what it
is but just like I just don't know a
situation where you're like like if
you're a dude
I don't ever remember another dude
slapping me that's another thing too
a slap is kind of like a it's it's I
don't know
slapping some not masculine about a slap
I don't know if a dude slapped you
how dare you you know I don't know if
that what is that I don't know that's
what I'm saying I don't ever remember a
dude slapping me
have you ever been slapped there's
another dude slapped you
it's like why are you assaulting me like
just hit me like Will Smith should have
just punched him like just do it real
what are you slapping him for slap is
almost like you know like slap is you
making a choice well if I punch this guy
I'll knock him out and I don't want to
do that but I still want to get physical
there's like a mental equation you're
doing in your head about slaps
okay that you go in you're consciously
being like uh
I don't want to hit this person right I
don't know seems like I've never been
slapped by another dude I don't know I
can't remember that ever happened
so
the times I've been slapped I can think
like oh uh uh a woman hit me wait did oh
did you guys hear that uh oh man the uh
yeah I gotta turn that off but thank you
uh Michael branch
who said I look forward to this every
week thank you very much I appreciate
you and thanks for the super chats
everybody
ah I always appreciate the super chats
um
yeah so anyways oh I have to do my I'm
not gonna do my
let's see did I get all the stories I
wanted to get out today I think I did I
did get all the stories yeah you know
shout out once again to Rachel you know
and and guys I remember my uh schedule
I'm gonna be in the Blue Room comedy
club in Springfield
Missouri April 13th to the 15th
Louisville Comedy Club April 20th to the
22nd comedy Mothership Joe Rogan's new
club in Austin April 28th to the 29th
and then I got some other dates coming
up in a future month so make sure you
guys check that out
not feeling well today guys so we're
just gonna cut it short today because I
had no ads or anything today anyway so
you know it's just me and you guys
chilling I appreciate when you guys come
every single week I appreciate the the
super chats I appreciate the engagement
I love when you guys make comments so
please do that get in the comments about
these things we're talking about because
I think it's having like a public
discourse I think is important let's
talk about stuff let's talk about issues
of the day and all that I don't think
there's anything wrong with that so bad
tick tock there's a 67 yes wow
interesting interesting results from the
poll so
maybe I should have made it more
specific you know I think but based off
that story about banning it for you know
kids without parental consent
how do you practically do that though
that's my thing like it should be if you
have a family plan phone it should be
this is a phone my kid has and my kid
can now not download anything unless you
know how you get like the two-factor
authentification you know what I mean
like it should be like your kid is
trying to download this app and then you
could be like no
you know what I mean they're gonna have
to figure it out like that how do they
implement it and all that stuff so
that's the interesting part right there
guys uh I'm not necessarily going to do
a rap recap right now because I want to
go back to my
and I have more like I said I got more
overlays and stuff coming you know I'm
trying to like really uh I'm trying to
step it up a notch you know what I mean
and I thank y'all
I'm coming and watching another episode
of your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway y'all thanks for coming out
thanks for being here
and I will see you next week
[Music]
foreign